[Music]
foreign
the mech is about to be seen in theaters
and just to get you ready for it we will
talk about the movie and real life
details about this gigantic sea monster
we will take a look at its Origins its
life cycle and everything that makes it
a deadly predator including its enemies
in the ocean so let's get into it so
starting with the origins and size in
real life the Megalodon Are
scientifically called the Autodesk
Megalodon is an extinct species of
mackerel shock that lifts approximately
23 to 3.6 million years ago it was once
thought to be related to the great white
shark but is now classified in the
extinct Family Auto Dawn today despite
being one of the largest Predators ever
its appearance and maximum size remains
uncertain estimates suggest that the
Megalodon could reach up to 20.3 meters
or 67 feet in length and weigh as much
as 103 metric tons or 114 shot tons
their teeth were thick and robust and
are the only fossil remains of it and
they were designed for capturing prey
and breaking bones
in the film the Megalodon is awakened
from its presume Extinction due to a
hidden ecosystem beneath a thermocline
layer in the ocean allowing it to
survive and grow to immense proportions
it was discovered in the Mariana's
Trench technically below the ocean floor
the Megalodon is portrayed as gigantic
and aggressive species of shark believed
to be extinct for millions of years but
in the present times it seems that there
are quite a number of them still alive
two that was seen in the first movie and
four more that will be seen in the
sequel the mix in the movie range from
being 60 to 70 feet or 18 to 21 meters
as in the smallest specimen to an
estimate 55 meters or 180 feet for the
biggest one in the second flick now
let's go to its growth and life cycle in
the real life the reproduction cycle of
the Megalodon shark is believed to have
involved live birth similar to modern
day sharks they likely give birth to
life young called pups instead of laying
eggs Megalodon use warm water Coastal
environments with abundant food and
protection from predators as Nursery
areas to birth their young but the
infant megalodons were estimated to be
around 3.5 meters or 11 feet in length
at their smallest they were vulnerable
to predation by other shark species
though such as the great hammerhead
shark and a snaggletooth shark but as
they become adults no other marine
animal dares to come near it well nearly
all except for one that we will tell you
later
the movie does not show the birth or
early life stages of the Megalodon it is
presumed that like the modern day sharks
the Megalodon would have hatched from X
laid by its mother in a safe and hidden
location or also like other species of
shelves it would have given birth to
life young which hatched inside the
modest womb this is evident with the
baby Mech being seen at the end of the
first movie escaping from the body of
the mother after it was developed by
other sharks as an adult the Megalodon
appears to be massive a massive creature
estimated to be over 100 feet or 30
meters in length bigger than anything
else
so what about its habitat this shot had
a widespread distribution with fossils
found in Europe Africa the Americas and
Australia primarily in subtropical to
temperate latitudes it could tolerate
temperatures ranging from 1 degrees to
24 degrees Celsius or 34 to 75 degrees
Fahrenheit due to its mesothermia which
allowed it to maintain a higher body
temperature than the surrounding water
the Megalodon occupied various Marine
environments including shallow Coastal
Waters coastal upwelling areas lagoons
Sandy literals and deep offshore Waters
its lifestyle was transient with adults
mainly inhabiting offshore regions and
potentially moving between Coastal and
oceanic Waters at different stages of
their life cycle mainly in their
reproductive stage going to the
shallower areas
but in the movie The Meg the habitat of
the Megalodon shot is primarily set in
the deep ocean waters particularly in
the unexplored depths of the Mariana's
Trench the Mariana stretch is one of the
deepest parts of the world's oceans and
in the movie it is depicted as an
ancient and hidden ecosystem teeming
with undiscovered marine life including
prehistoric Megalodon sharks Krakens and
other species the Megalodon is believed
to have survived in this remote and dark
environment far away from Human
civilization for millions of years and
as the plot progresses the Megalodon
escapes from its hidden habitat possibly
due to human activities or other factors
and the Sharks begin to venture into the
accessible Waters posing a significant
threat to the characters and nearby
coastal areas asserting their dominance
all over the ocean including the Bays
the coast the beaches and the offshore
regions
and lastly let's talk about its
competitors the Megalodon co-existed
with other apex predators including
macro raptoral sperm whales some of
these whales like the Olivia Tom malvale
reached gigantic sizes estimated between
13.5 to 17.5 meters or 44 to 57 feet
around the same size of the mag by the
late myosin Epoch around 11 million
years ago macro raptoral whales
experienced a decline in abundance and
diversity other species like the arsenas
sytoniensis the fossil killer whale
possibly filled their ecological niche
in the pliocene and its role as a pack
Predator targeting prey larger than
itself although disputed is quite
reasonable yet the Megalodon's presence
may have led to some competitive
exclusion with other large shark species
avoiding regions it inhabits by sticking
to colder Waters
so here we can see that the extingular
whales the liviaton melvolais and even
other large shark species were its
competitors killing each other at
different stages of their life cycle and
it also depends whether the shark or the
other species were larger in size this
was a very competitive space and it's
the survival of the fittest
as for the movie there were no signs of
anything that can touch a feet on a
Megalodon shark well in the first movie
except for another specimen of its own
species like when we saw the bigger one
consume the first Mech that was captured
by the boat however in the sequel we
will get a chance to see sea monster
fights between two species the Meg and
the cephalopod giant that we shall call
the Kraken it is unclear as to how the
Kraken came to be or what part of the
food chain it holds in the Mariana's
Trench but in the coastal Waters it will
go face to face with a giant shark it
could theoretically kill a Meg if the
Kraken wraps its body around the shark
and suffocated by sinking to the ocean
floor thereby depriving the Meg of
oxygen since sharp gills only work when
the animal is moving around so this is
the movie competitor of the Megalodon
shark
anyway that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel take care fam